let's say that we have the number five
and we're asked what number do we add to
the number five to get to zero and you
might already know this but i'll just
draw it out so let's say we have a
number line right over here and zero is
sitting right over there and we are we
are already sitting here at 5.
so to go from 5 to 0 we have to go five
spaces to the left we have to go five
spaces to the left and if we're going
five spaces to the left that means that
we are adding negative five so if we add
negative five right here then that is
going to get us back to zero
that is going to get us back right over
here to zero and you probably already
knew this and this is a pretty maybe
common sense thing right here but
there's a fancy word for it called the
additive inverse property and all the
additive i'll just write it down i think
it's kind of ridiculous that it's given
such a fancy word for such a simple idea
additive inverse property and it's just
the idea that if you have a number and
you add the additive inverse of the
number which is which is what most
people call the negative of the number
if you add the negative of the number to
your number you're going to get back to
zero because they have the same they
have the same size you could view it
that way they both have a magnitude of
five but this is going five to the right
and then you're going five back to the
left similarly if you started at
if you started let me draw another
number line right over here if you
started at negative three
if you're starting right over here at
negative three so you've already moved
three spaces to the left and someone
says well what do i have to add to
negative three what do i have to add to
negative three to get back to zero
well i have to move three spaces to the
right now and three spaces to the right
is in the positive direction so i have
to add positive three
so if i add positive three to negative
three i will get zero so in general if i
have
if i have any number if i have 1 million
725
314 and i say what do i need to add to
this to get back to zero well i have to
essentially go in the opposite direction
i have to i have to go in the leftwards
direction so i'm going to subtract the
same amount or i could say i'm going to
add the additive inverse or i'm going to
add the negative version of it so this
is going to be the same thing as adding
negative 1 million 725 thousand three
hundred and fourteen and that'll just
get me that'll get me back to zero
similarly if i say what number do i have
to add to negative seven to get to zero
well if i'm already at negative seven i
have to go seven to the right so i have
to add positive seven and these this is
going to be equal to zero and this all
comes from the general idea five plus
negative five five plus the negative of
five or five plus the additive inverse
of five you can just view this
as another way of five minus five and if
you have five of something you take away
five you've learned many many years ago
that that is just going to get you to
zero